tu es un héros mec tu paieras plus
jamais un seul verre aussi longtemps
qu'il sera en vie il ya des tas de
journalistes surexcités dans ta fenêtre
ça à vrai dire que mon pote et à jeter
un coup d'oeil tout ça c'est rien pour
toi tous ces gros cons d'adorateurs dit
d'elle une vraie rockstar mais à attend
il faut que tu vois la vidéo c'est
l'émeute de l'immeuble
ça grouille leurs portes tiens j'étais
là dessus c'est moi je lui ai dit
quelques mots jetés presque toujours
sincère ça va comment vis tu as l'air 2
qui me donne certes des movies je me
sens comme en banque
j'arrive pas de rideau ce qui te suivent
que le médoc tu as poisot l'âme c'est un
générique du xanax hydrocodone générique
de la vicodine tombales en chef des
génériques où il a dit roman finale pour
l'amateur ou quoi le docteur tu viens
sont les 100 personnes à brigue
tu va amener mes clopes oui j'ai reçu
ton [ __ ] de messages et oui j'étais
amené des [ __ ] de clopes
j'ai de la tient une cartouche la face
si c'était moi je m'en venir et une
direct dans la jambe